I just talked to Steven Spielberg at the  AFI Life Achievement Awards and we just  found out what he's doing next what John  Williams if you could have one to just  score your life the song starts playing  every time you go to do something big I  heard that you had a hand in picking the  new young Han Solo and that you  discovered him in a bot mitzvah video he  was yes he was in a Bob Pizza video that  my daughter acted with him in for their  best friend Layla and they showed me the  video and I loved it and I got him an  agent that sort of all began I thought  he had a lot of promise in comedy I  didn't know he was gonna go rogue drama  he was so funny in this video I thought  I have found the next really funny  comedian but he's made most of his  choices have been in drama and people  don't know how really funny he is I  gotta ask you really quick about Indiana  Jones five will John Williams come back  and forth John Williams will come back  and score absurd